have I ever spoken to Richard's wife on
the air I don't think so but I don't
know that we have hey Kristen this is so
interesting and I'm gonna read you
straight from the notes you know it just
shows you the disconnect between Richard
and reality
Kristen complained that Richard never
cleans up after himself or throws things
away
Richard leaves empty bags of chips all
over the place it's attracting ants he
also leaves empty beer bottles
everywhere where is Richard Richard get
on here get on your zoom oh you he's
watching buddy you might hear buddy in
the background Kristen hey Richard how
you doing man what are you gonna do
how's bubbie doing Richard how old is
bubbie at this point he's 2 years and 6
months what your wife is saying is she
needs you to step up and an adult and
clean up after yourself what would you
do if she stopped cleaning up after you
I'd be living like I did while I was
living in a storage unit I had stuff
there's I need to get out of that
mentality let me bring this up too while
I got you on the phone I want to help
your wife out here Richard and Kristen
disagree about how much Richard showers
according to Richard he is showering
more than ever under quarantine
Kristen once Kristen says it isn't true
at all she says she has to force Richard
to take showers when he starts to smell
too bad my mom and I heard him on the
show before quarantine happen and he
would always say like oh my god he's so
full of [ __ ] because he I think over
would be like on work nights so he has
more than enough time
it sounds like you have two children you
have Bobby and you right I mean when you
got to tell your adult husband to go
shower because he smells richard says he
showers after every workout again
Kristen says is true the day she had to
make him shower after he worked out
because he went to lay down on the couch
as long as he showers like the night
before work out that he's good but if
you wait today it gets kind of like
exactly like you know milk Richard you
want you once said that you enjoy
sitting in your own Musk and taking it
all in is that true you've never liked
taking your finger and put it in that
area between your balls in your thigh
and smelled it yeah I have and guess
what it says to me time to shower I
think Bobby is making a lot of noise
because he's smelling Richards stink and
he's probably like my god yeah Kristen
who shits their pants more Richard or
bubby listened to the show and I'm like
oh I didn't know that ever happens is
that the Richard that's right and just
so everybody knows I'm not gonna be
showering or using deodorant or brushing
my face I'm the crusty Kristi